yah hello and welcome into another tea
session let's play some games um always
try on some of those a little bit longer
blitz games but it's difficult to get an
opponent and I don't want to sit there
for minutes but I'm going to give it a
shot
generally not so easy
get one okay so let's play a Sicilian if
you somehow I don't know if anybody does
follow the ratings you see that I got
refunded the games against the against
the cheetah that I played on last Sunday
morning I mean that never got to YouTube
I'm sorry pretty early morning
okay this is a bit of a sideline the
bishop takes f6 them at this point
because black also has f5 and there is
some what people sometimes ya feel is
some even stronger than bee fire but I'm
not so sure about it and it's additional
theoretical workload so not really
interested
yeah c4 is interesting in this pollution
it some line that is not so well
explored
leads to gambit play as you see black is
simply giving up the whole queenside
form all the activity that he gets the
ante is just taking everything
um I think I have to castle first here
if I'm not mistaken it's not a line that
I am checked very extensively for the
fight like Magnus course because it is
pretty clear that black has a very good
position just a matter of how good it is
so let's take a very good is Sam I mean
maybe an overstatement I mean black has
some not winning or anything but you
just immediately have this feeling that
something went wrong for Wyatt
yeah if you look at this position that
cannot be great for just one pawn like
has some yeah the fantastically placed
night white cannot castle yes Queen a5
and so on there there are many things
going for black and white um yeah hasn't
spent any time in this game and already
I think is in some sort of critical
situation
and see what team what he does
you know this is expected at one
the question is now how to continue
there are a couple of interesting ideas
I connected with them
connected with efore for example
you know I think this should work here
let's do this I take first here
now I play efore
using this little we need for you piayed
tactic to open up the bishop and the key
moves that I have is rook takes a three
em route takes a three
and then the diagonal opens up
just a question what the best way play
is
Oh
you
I can just just about holders
yeah yeah I don't have Queen a5 with a
check
that is not so good
you
it's not as clear as I thought
you
I thought that Luke takes a three should
be more or less a winning shot but it's
not it's not really the case
No
whenever I screwed up the move water how
many did
maybe e-form okay I have to have to play
this game let's go
I still have good compensation it's not
really the point but I thought the game
would have been already over
at this point
can we do this it's very early
Knight f4 Queen g5 should win
main point is I want to prepare Queen g5
get the Queen on an active square
they're really remarkable
point about this position or positions
like that is just how active all the
pieces are you check every black piece
some sort of active only the queen needs
some improvement and 2g5 would
definitely be good
okay so we go to g5
as the tech the night
No
Ruki eight
hey III
and to cover a cavity for of course
you
I need to watch the time a little bit
I'm a little bit behind
another idea poom poom sorry my voice is
a bit of is to play
oh look lift
just for the attack I mean as it is so
often in this fashion cough the white
nights are just like completely
misplaced on the queenside
it don't help to defend at all
eggs wanna until they would
any significance
came
what's going on here
I'd take and play a three and then what
resigns I presume
No
you
it's so difficult to
to defend positions like that this is
often just objectively bad and then you
still have to find the moves that
somehow um yeah avoid the immediate loss
I still think I made a mistake and we
will see this here
so okay yeah and the debt is already
already completely winning for black it
was very greedy but why did um okay
Bishop d3 and now okay Bishop d7 this is
better even yeah yes the night going to
go yeah but um what I did is also not
bad I think I just screwed up the move
autumn um okay if was given us best
I was thinking during the game that
maybe this one would have been better
because Knight c3 and Danny for that's
what I thought but it doesn't seem to be
a significant difference
like him is already having fantastic
compensation basically no matter what I
mean winning objective flame
compensation so but if one was was okay
it seems now okay five yeah I thought
about it but I wasn't quite sure
[Music]
deaf fire I mean you you just applied
less forcing moves and still was kind of
okay in 92 was the way to defend
well
in g5 look a forum was like that so keep
a good initiative
so here I don't know that it just it's
just so difficult to play
whoever is quite logical and to get rid
of the yes he wanted to do it
differently with that just doesn't work
at all like a sir
immediately a winning
let's go for another game um yeah maybe
the normal had same its time control 3+2
or scart blitz
Oscar Dianna
so I got a request recently to play a
bit of Moy efore repertoire and I can do
that
even though sometimes I am recognized
that I have already forgotten there
quite a bit of what I analyzed in the e4
repertoire keep it simple for it's just
already quite a bit of time since I
wrote this and as I've written this um
and if you forget stuff
yeah black setup here is a little bit
uncommon but
probably not something that I can
straight away so I'm just playing
normal moves to develop and germ claim
that my piece placement that is a bit
better than blacks is enough for small
edge
you force a bit odd
that
I can take it for now I wonder is that
porn isn't that a bit weak
maybe
you
if one looks weak to me in this position
it's a little bit unsupported f5 is not
possible
yeah let's move on yeah there are a
couple of things
that don't feel quite right him
mm-hmm okay
this is the simplest thing Bishop a4 to
see - yeah let's do that
not sure if it's best a move like Knight
c4 or Knight f1 also looked quite
attractive going for Knight e3 and g3
this kind of this kind of a DM
Bishop c2 is fairly straightforward how
does he even keep the pawn I'm not quite
sure how
you
you notice we're not clear to me how he
saves upon
ooh six
a six of almost okay
it's really a bit mysterious
you
maybe he thought Bishop a4 had a
completely different idea I don't know
a6 is a kind of know what does this move
his own 25
hang on
maybe
yeah if I can
refute dad
like really refuted
shaky move but
you
hmm and don't see anything super clear
after after Queen d5
maybe queen bee one I mean that that's
the obvious move have pileup only four
maybe this is enough
yeah by now his time is downward he
dashed out everything quickly and then
the position was already too too bad
Quinn b1m problem it just feels a little
bit unnatural to move
you have to think about some desperation
sacrifices for example on one deformed
if these could maybe work and the
likelihood of moves like that working
increases if you were decentralize
pieces like will be one but don't think
I with don't think anything's wrong
there and he's taking ages
very strange
maybe maybe something happened on his
end him never know answer the door
I know okay so get a new game creepy one
was I think just winning the poor next
you
yeah so another three plus two
here we go zap on okay
wrong
Scandinavian
and this line I never understood I just
think that white is always a bit better
and this is just an incorrect gambit
it's not like entirely unplayable in a
blitz game but it's very close now is he
going threatening if I if I don't think
so I think I can probably castle first
just six now I can go d4 here right
there's nothing
wrong about dad okay so
like it's just a pawn down for nothing
there should be five checking I think is
always a slight advantage for white even
if it does not play c6
okay so see going with night F form
something like that maybe
my dears 94
in 93
stir
yeah getting rid of this this pin
makes it easier to play this position
yeah the simplest way to play this is to
just take him
I wonder it's not bad
53 and just start to convert the pawn
now also other other pretty good options
like taking on c6 and cool 95
not entirely certain but this is this is
very very simple and
and I think easy-to-handle can also take
c6 play 95 that's also not bad would
immediately regain the bishop is also
good right let's do this tough to say
yeah what's what's best
and so I'm getting back one of the
bishops immediately
looked him like the least attractive
option
the bishop on g6 is just a really bad
piece and I'm in complete control him
swords
make sure that c5 doesn't happen and a5
probably also doesn't work
I even have rook air-five as a good spot
for the rook
you
young is he five a threat if I move okay
five
No
you
now the point about this is that the
rukon a5 is completely safe we can never
attack it and it prevents every break on
the fifth-ranked including this one I'm
a little bit um irritated that he played
it anyway
this stadium it can just take another
pawn right
you
not sure about this
you
Jim just two pawns
yeah probably him
it keeps the pawn structure
perfectly sound
we have 3m there is maybe looketh age
you
need to speed up a little bit
with the increment it's not such a worry
but
still a little bit quicker would help
I need to get the a1 look into play
and this is in fact
not Jam super obvious how this should
happen
which I mean he really cannot do all
that much
an important point is simply that
g6 is such a useless piece it doesn't do
anything
just stepping outside off of checks on
the back rank IAM and then try to
improve maybe f4 f5 is an idea i need to
make some sort of headway
okay
and I'll see five for you
and now I should be able to play either
t1 or e1 so rook e1
hmm now um f4 f5 yeah let's F we will
take don't do that okay so I have three
then
you
it's always like that put put the Queen
below the board
in East six
now as the bishop is always hanging
[Music]
you
he might take it but
game is pretty much
very simple win
you
young
you
yeah I just assumed briefly show I mean
this is just an incorrect opening with
c6 you just take the pawn and there's
nothing happening but there should be
five is a good line anyway Vaz after
Bishop d7 B should be 295 st for white
always has a slight advantage because
it's just a somewhat better structure
into the 97 um you can simply develop
you don't need to do anything fancy you
can some do something so d4 or castles
it's not a huge difference this is
always a bit of an advantage as white as
a structural um I'm structurally better
central position by 75 under control
again this is not winning or anything
but it's just very comfortable
you
okay okay there is no rating limit I
guess
a bit of a low opponents rating
you
they just
send a nice message there okay let's see
what he does against my to night system
okay
yeah okay we will probably now see an
interesting variation and Jim this is a
case where
ah interesting it takes immediately
yeah this is a new idea taking here with
the F pawn this is something that I did
not include in my keep it simple efore
repertoire because at the time this idea
was not known a deserve new innovation
pins the reason two years
but it will be added to my
chasuble product of course you cannot
add something like that to a print
Bachman sir
the typical disadvantage of print um but
it will be added to the chess over cause
this F takes idea it's very interesting
P sorry
okay yeah White has excellent attacking
chances in this line which is sometimes
even an understatement
okay let's see
g5 or do we have anything even better
[Music]
I think I'm going to play this first the
move f6 is irritating me here a little
bit I wonder if I did something wrong
Oh
you
yes f6
you
pairen air I mean I I wonder good g5 and
completely
bind down yeah he's got to smooth
hmm
you
it's not totally clear if this is fine
for black or not but this is already
more than you should have gotten
you
okay now maybe Queenie one intending
Queen age form and I'm also looking at
if five so that this is not so easy to
play
the ideas Queen age form and after h6
Queen age five
No
[Music]
still think I didn't do it and play that
in the best possible way
you
you saw that this is possible but I
didn't quite believe he would play it
okay
is there way No
he just returns upon to free up his
position
not really
certain that it helps
well it should be good for wider
[Music]
so it's
sacrifices and that it's just a peace
sacrifice maybe that maybe this can be
played 96 Queen takes Queen d7
and then move like let's say Quincy
three
you
yeah it's a bit weird but it seems to
work
what a strange game sometimes this is
chess
yeah seems to work
I mean it's not completely completely
odd that it that this works because I'm
a little bit uncoordinated if I from
probably yeah I didn't think it was good
but maybe it is good
here my ideas to him play Bishop d3 93
which should be okay and 90 85 I take
the bishop
that would be some
time scramble anyway
know that that cannot work come on
now number calcium
you
mm gab that was interesting
all of a sudden that
that he had this is technically based
counterplay
you
yeah it's true
wasn't quite necessary to allow
you
yeah but okay it's just a piece really
nothing else about this
you
[Music]
yeah just thinking about
as technical way to proceed
you
and night III would have been a bit a
bit more annoying
now the knight is strapped in addition
to everything
you know I just want to want to check
this briefly I think I probably made a
mistake they are so Bishop d3 knight c6
castles
that is right there should be seven and
here it's best to take yeah okay I'm not
familiar yet with the line I would add
that as mentioned to the to the rabbit
rabbit and I'm not really familiar yet
with everything yeah this is in fact
looks very strong because the bishop is
actually not well placed here you have
to guard g5 and so on yeah this looks
very good for white and the engine
confirms this yeah
King edge one takes this is still pretty
interesting but the f6 ATM really looked
to look good okay yeah 95 was already
killing black okay I didn't see this
idiom
after taking I have Queen h5 and that is
very strong
this-this-this and then probably bishop
yeah but should have six is good yeah
that looks nice
winning attack for white made in 16 it's
a bit like AI was very strong
so my g4 wasn't good and then he got
this f6 based counter play Knight g5
again was winning
Wow I didn't see anything here in this
game the pointer said Bishop h7 now
exactly am Bishop h7 is in such a killer
okay so and I missed some things he five
was interesting
so take stakes
takes and now okay he I could have taken
I thought I couldn't take because here
Queen takes Queen is seven Quincy three
and I didn't think rook a two would work
it just looks so awkward
they are probably just work it does not
really have anything
[Music]
Yeah right yeah so I could have taken
this ah he he bluffed me so to same okay
um let's go for a new game
okay we have 36 minutes in the session I
wanted to do roughly 45 I have to get
some things done
you
all right takes away
I always wondered if I can but I think
it's not possible Tim put out challenges
in multiple time controls
OKs a somewhat higher rated opponent the
real kid
you
after 93 you probably don't even need
Quincy seven
I would probably play it anyway at the
end
but you can make an argument for Queenie
seven here
nope don't understand the movement hmm
nope no clue what this does
you
each voice very strange
so I can play night
for him
yeah okay you can argue then after night
reform is going to play um age five
you
you
okay interesting
you
and I don't know it's just - it's just
too tempting
to to grab the the total Bishop pair
here
you
okay this is one of those games where I
never ever expect to move and this is
sometimes I just have this idea that if
they play if they never play a move that
I expect I just start to play quick more
quickly because it's kind of pointless
to think about what they do you will
never guess a move so just do your thing
and see what happens just a pragmatic
approach
I would have never guessed this kind of
thing ignite e 2g 3 H wah and then take
with the app porn it's probably not so
bad I'm not saying it's bad it's just
like it's completely not what I would
expect and then it makes it a bit
sometimes a bit of a moot point to try
to exactly guess what they would play
ping
you just have a completely different
idea what's going on
yeah no way is he castling queenside I I
guess
I have no forget about it I'm ever never
get a move
I am now I'm just going to do it anyway
let's do it
okay
this is probably useful
let's see six is not always
that you can never take here because of
Queen g5
you
[Music]
you
I wonder if it could be an idea to
double here and then play for c4 or a
combination of b5 and C form something
like that
you
nice moving this a night away from
[Music]
the f5 square makes g5 a bit more
interesting
anyway I'm drifting a little bit
time-wise
maybe a look at the seven I would have
been
warm
more precise
you
yeah
be a little bit more
Jim
yeah this position is absolutely not so
clear but I always have a hard time to
believe in a position where I have the
total bishop am I mean where my opponent
has two knights and I have two bishops I
always think that
well I don't know
that I have to do something
be bad to get into trouble
don't see why I shouldn't take it
what a memo we're looking something
you
some of this has a deja vu kind of
quality this game
yeah that wasn't ideal
he somehow has something here no
yeah
yeah then 95
it's pretty easy to
- blunder here
okay I didn't play this well
oh okay that's nice
nice shot
it's a full/queen right yeah that that
was terribly played by me
really bad I mean a position like that
it's just it's difficult I thought I
would be like I'm always better here two
bishops and against two knights it's
usually just just to win yeah basically
and it's probably then I miss played
something around here
because that that I cannot really
believe to be anything good
so
yeah I have to probably find the right
plane in this position
[Music]
you
see our computer just wants to go a5 b5
and yeah man it makes some sense
six doesn't seem to help me at all
you
you
you
you
arrrrgh f6 was possible add that was
CERN was interesting
yeah a six is good
you
I mean it was it was clear that I
shouldn't ya lose quickly word
c4 doesn't work just doesn't work
that is probably all
impossible to defend v5 is hanging and
this is an immediate kill
yeah what can you do man pretty good
game there okay guys thanks for watching
this session I'll be back tomorrow have
a good day
bye bye